o pessoal bem vindo a mais um vídeo e
hoje vou ensinar como fazer mais uma de
opção dizendo coisas bastante simples
que vocês provavelmente vão ter em casa
acho que vocês vão ter que comprar é uma
garrafa daquelas provas por conquistas
como a gordura especial que vocês vão
ver
é no tutorial maior proteção e que está
a arma seja devem ter identificado tudo
que vocês vão precisar a e agora fazer
um texto então nos abonos da stop mas
vocês podem mudar de tamanho pois é ela
quem ali é provável que você não vai
desistir porque está mesmo muito rápido
e agora vou ensinar como fazer esta arma
passa passa a criei um celular de uma
bebida energética e para desportistas
mas tem que ter essa tempo aqui do dane
o site o link só pode sair quando vocês
tocarem na extremidade da tampa
existem várias medidas semelhantes de
uma sustentação de frente então é muito
importante vocês verem o voto
hoje eu cortei agora um poder sendo uma
caneta só tirei aquela parte da rosca
escola nunca achei na abertura mas é
muito importante que o candidato fique
bem centralizada ficar torta um tiro vai
ser provado que eu tenho aqui uma
pistola do silicone e um investidor de
bola de futebol ou então bicicleta
aprender a pistola usando fita e quando
você usar em fita e não cola porque a
cola
quando vocês forem cheiro vai se
aprendendo aos poucos o toque mas a fita
pode mudar de lugar mas vai continuar a
manter o investidor lá
vejam que eu encaixei rafa e vou fazer
agora um furo com
um pioneiro se passar esta agulha não
sei como é que chama e vou pôr bastante
cola a volta
se vocês quiserem podem usar uma super
cola por forçar ainda mais esta conexão
e para finalizar cruzado uma tampa
grande e tirem o centro esta tampa vai
ajudar é que o mecanismo funciona ou
seja em garrafa vai bater nessa tampa
verde e vai libertar o guarda dessa
maneira como vocês podem ver aqui é
precisam de mim é muito boa mas porquê
porque quando vocês vamos parar tem que
fazer isso o banho rápido seja tem que
puxar o gatilho rápido e ao fazerem isso
vocês mexem muito a arma
agora se vocês quiserem que os separava
mais certeiro
vocês têm que agarrar com as duas mãos e
encostar o cabo da arma contra o vosso
ombro e vocês vão ver esse senhor na
parte final
agora eu terei o áudio por que e como
cada estranho então seria dizer agora
podem usar de tamanho mas tenham cuidado
caí sondado é e seis altos ganhos afim
muito obrigado a desistir até a próxima